Welcome back to six zero,
nine,
nine artificial general intelligence.
Today we have Richard Moise.
He's the founder and managing director
of article 36,
a UK based not for profit organization,
working to prevent the unintended,
unnecessary and unacceptable harm caused
by certain weapons,
including autonomous weapons and nuclear
weapons.
He will talk with us today about
autonomous weapon systems and the
context of Ai Safety.
This is an extremely important topic for
engineers,
humanitarians,
legal minds,
policymakers,
and everybody involved in paving the
path for a safe,
positive future for ai in our society,
which I hope is what this course is
about.
Richard flew all the way from the UK to
visit us today in snow in Massachusetts,
so please give him a warm welcome.
Thank you.
Thanks very much lex and thank you all
for coming out.
I was,
like I said,
I work for a not for profit organization
based in the UK.
We specialize in thinking about policy
and legal frameworks around weapon
technologies particularly and generally
about how to establish more constraining
policy and legal frameworks around
around weapons and I guess I'm mainly
going to talk today about these issues
of to what extent we should enable
machines to kill people to make
decisions to kill people.
It's,
I think,
a conceptually very interesting topic.
Quite challenging in lots of ways.
There's lots of unstable terminology,
lots of sort of blurry boundaries.
My own background,
the sidewalk on weapons policy issues
that I've worked on,
the development of have two legal,
international legal treaties prohibiting
certain types of weapons.
I worked on the development of 2008
convention on cluster munitions,
which prohibits cluster bombs and worked
on our organization.
Pyre pioneered the idea of a treaty
prohibition on nuclear weapons,
which was agreed last year in the UN and
we're part of the steering group of
Icann,
the international campaign to abolish
nuclear weapons,
which won the Nobel peace prize last
year,
so that was a good year for us.
The issue of autonomous weapons,
killer robots which are going to talk
about the day.
We're also part of an NGO,
nongovernmental organization coalition
on this issue called the campaign to
stop killer robots.
It's a good name.
However,
I think when we get into some of the
details of the issue,
we'll find that perhaps the snappiness
of the name in a way masks some of the
complexity that lies underneath this,
but this is a live issue in
international policy,
in legal discussions at the United
Nations for the last several years,
three or four years now that are being
groups of governments coming together to
discuss autonomous weapons and whether
or not there should be some new legal
instrument that,
uh,
the tackles this,
this issue.
So it's a,
it's a live political issue that is
being debated in,
in policy,
legal circles.
And really my,
my comments a day are going to be
speaking to that context.
I guess I'm going to try and give us a
bit of a briefing about what the issues
are in this international debate,
how different actors,
a orientating to these issues.
Some of the conceptual models that we,
we use in that.
So I'm not really going to give you a
particular sales pitches to what you
should think about this issue though.
My own biases are probably going to be
fairly evident during the process,
but really to try and lay out a bit of a
sense of,
of how these,
uh,
these questions debated in the
international political scene and maybe
in a way that's useful for reflecting on
sort of wider questions of how a AI
technologies might be orientate it to an
approach by,
uh,
by policy makers and,
and,
and the legal framework.
So in terms of the structure of my
comments,
I'm gonna talk a bit about some of the
pros and cons that are put forward a
around autonomous weapons or movements
towards greater autonomy in weapons
systems.
Uh,
I'm going to talk a bit more about the
political legal framework within,
within which these discussions are
taking place.
And then I'm going to try to sort of lay
out some of the models,
the conceptual models that we're as an
organization have developed and are sort
of using a in relation to these issues.
And perhaps to reflect a bit on where I
see the,
the political conversation,
the legal conversation on this going at
an international level and maybe just
finally to try to reflect on or just
draw out some more general thoughts that
I think occurred to me a about what some
of those says about thinking about ai
functions in a,
in different social social roles.
Um,
but before getting into that sort of
pros and cons type type stuff,
I just wanted to start by suggesting a
bit of a sort of conceptual timeline
because one of the things this could be
the president,
one of the things you find when we
start,
when you say to somebody who will work
on this issue of autonomous weapons,
they tend to orientate to it.
And in two fairly distinct ways.
Some people will say,
oh,
you mean om drones and you know,
we know drones are they being used,
uh,
in the world today.
And that's kind of an issue here in the
present.
Right?
But other people,
most of the media,
and certainly pretty much every media
photo editor thinks she talking about
terminator of hair.
Maybe even a skynet thrown in,
so this is a sort of advanced,
futuristic,
Saifai orientation to the,
to the issues.
My thinking about this,
I come from a background of,
of working on the impact of weapons in
the present.
I'm less,
I'm less concerned about this area of my
thinking and my anxieties or concerns
around this issue.
Don't come from,
from this area.
I'll do this light a bit wiggly here
because I also don't want to suggest
there's any kind of,
you know,
telia logical certainty going on here.
This is just an imaginary timeline,
but I think it's important just in terms
of situating where I'm coming from in
the debate that I'm definitely not
starting at that end.
And yet in the political discussion
amongst governments and states,
well you have people come in and it all
sorts of different positions along here.
Imagining a little autonomous weapons
may existed,
you know,
somewhere along this,
this sort of spectrum.
So I'm going to think more about stuff
that's going on around here and how some
of our conceptual model is really built
around some of this thinking.
Not so much actually armed drones,
but some other,
some other systems.
But my background before I started
working on policy and law around weapons
was,
um,
was setting up and managing landmine
clearance operations overseas and well,
they'd been around for.
I'd been around for quite a long time,
like months.
Um,
and I think it's interesting just to
start with,
just to reflect on the basic
anti-personnel landmine.
A simple,
but it gives us,
I think some sort of useful entry points
into thinking about what an autonomous
weapon system might be in its most
simple form.
Uh,
if we think about a landmine,
well,
essentially we have a person and as an
input into the landmine and there's a
function that goes on here.
Pressure is greater than x person.
They tried on the landmine.
There's a basic mechanical algorithm
goes on and you get an output.
That explosion that goes back against
the person who taught on the Lamont.
So it's a fairly simple system of a
signal,
a sensor taking a signal from the
outside world.
The landmine is viewing the outside
world through its sensor to basic
pressure plate and according to a
certain calculus here,
you got output and it's directed back at
this person and it's a loop.
And that's one of the things that I
think is fundamental essentially to
understanding the idea of autonomous
weapons.
And in a way this is where the autonomy
comes in,
that there's no other person intervening
in this process at any point.
There's just a sort of straightforward
relationship from the person or object
that has initiated the,
uh,
the system back into the,
back into the effects that are being,
that are being applied.
So in some ways,
we'll come back to this later and think
about how some of the basic building
blocks of this,
uh,
maybe they're not thinking about other
weapons systems and weapons technologies
as they're developing and maybe thinking
about landmines and thinking about these
processes of technological change.
We see a number of different,
uh,
dynamics at play in this sort of
imaginary timeline.
Anti personnel,
land mines of course a static.
They just sit in the ground where you
left them.
But we get more and more mobility
perhaps as we go through this system.
Certainly drones and other systems that
I'll talk about,
you start to see more mobility in the,
in the weapon system.
Perhaps greater sophistication of
sensors,
I mean a a basic pressure plate.
Just gauging,
wait,
that's a very simple a census structure
for interrogating the world.
We have much more sophisticated a sensor
systems and weapons now.
So we have weapons systems now that are
looking at radar signatures.
They're looking at the heat shapes of
objects and we'll come back and talk
about that.
But more sophistication of sensors and
more sophistication of the,
um,
of the computer algorithms that are
basically interrogating those sensor,
the sensor inputs.
I'm perhaps a little bit as well of a
movement in this sort of trajectory from
physically very unified objects always
sort of wrestle slightly whether this is
the word I want,
but it's a sort of self contained
entity.
The landmine.
Whereas as we move in this direction,
maybe we see more dispersal of functions
through different three different
systems.
And I think that's another dynamic that
when we think about the development of
autonomy and weapon systems,
it might not all live in one place
physically moving around in one place.
It can be,
uh,
an array of different systems
functioning in different,
in different places,
uh,
perhaps for people with a sort of ai
type of mindset.
Maybe there's some sort of movement from
more specific types of ai functioning
here,
use of different specific ai functions
here to something more general going in
this direction.
I'm wary of necessarily buying straight
forward into that,
but maybe you could see some movement in
that sort of direction.
So I just want to sort of put this to
one side for now,
but we'll come back to it and think
about some systems that are existing
here that I think sort of raise issues
for us and around which we could expand
some,
some models.
But I just wanted to have this in mind
when thinking about this.
So we're not necessarily,
we're definitely not for me thinking
about a humanoid robots walking around
fighting like a soldier,
a rather.
We're thinking about developments and
trajectories.
We can see coming out of established
military systems now,
so I was going to talk now a bit about
the political and the legal context.
Obviously there's a lot of complexity in
the worlds of politics and legal
structures and I don't want to get too
bogged down in it,
but I think in terms of understanding
the basics of this,
a debate on the international landscape
have to have a bit of background in that
area.
Essentially there's,
I think three main types of
international law that we're concerned
with here and again,
concerned with international law rather
than domestic legislation,
which any individual state can put in
place whatever domestic legislation they
want.
We're looking at the international legal
landscape.
Basically you have international human
rights law which applies in pretty much
all circumstances and it involves the
right to life and the right to dignity
and,
uh,
various other,
legal protections people.
And then particularly prominent in this
debate if you have what's called
international humanitarian law,
which is the rules that govern behavior
during armed conflict and provide
obligations on military is engaged in
armed conflict for how they have to
conduct themselves.
This isn't the legal framework that
decides whether it's okay to have a war
or not.
This is a legal framework that once you
have in the war,
this is the obligations that you've got
to,
you've got to follow.
And it,
it basically includes rules that say,
you know,
you're not allowed to directly kill
civilians.
You've got to aim your military efforts
at the forces of the,
of the enemy that enemy competence.
You're not allowed to kill civilians
directly or deliberately,
but you are allowed to kill some
civilians as long as you don't kill too
many of them for the military advantage
that you're trying to achieve.
So there's a sort of balancing acts like
this.
This is called proportionality.
Nobody ever really knows where the
balance lies,
but it's a,
it's a sort of principle of the law
that,
uh,
while she can kill civilians,
you mustn't kill an excessive number of
civilians.
These are general rules.
These apply pretty much to all states,
uh,
in,
um,
conflict situations.
And then you have treaties on specific
weapon,
a specific weapon types.
And this is really where you have
weapons that are considered to be
particularly problematic in some way,
and it's decided a group of states
decides to develop and put in place
agree,
a treaty that,
uh,
that applies specifically to those,
to those weapons.
I think it's important to recognize that
the illegal treaties are all developed
and agreed by states that are agreed by
international governments talking
together,
negotiating what they think the law
should say.
And they generally only bind on states
if they choose to adopt that legal
instrument.
So,
uh,
I guess what I'm emphasizing there is a
sense that these are sort of social
products in a way that political
products,
it isn't the sort of magical law that's
come down from on high,
perfectly written to match the needs of
humanity.
It's a negotiated outcome developed by a
complicated set of actors who may or may
not agree with each other and all sorts
of things.
And what I means is there's quite a lot
of wiggle room in these legal
frameworks.
And quite a lot of uncertainty within
the lawyers of international
humanitarian law will tell you that's
not true.
But that's because there are
particularly keen on that legal
framework,
but in reality there's a lot of,
um,
a lot of fuzziness to,
to what some of the legal provisions or
some of the legal provisions say.
And it also means that the extent to
which this law binds on people and bears
on people is also require some social
enactment.
There's not a sort of world police who,
who could follow up on all of these,
uh,
these legal frameworks.
It requires a sort of social function
from states and from other actors to
keep articulating a sense of the
importance of these legal rules and keep
trying to put pressure on other factors
to,
to a chord with them.
So the issue of autonomous weapons is in
discussion at the United Nations under a
framework called the UN Convention on
conventional weapons.
And this is a body that has the capacity
to agree new protocols,
new treaties essentially on specific
weapon systems.
And that means that diplomats from lots
of countries,
diplomats from the US,
from the UK,
from Russia,
and Brazil and China and other countries
of the world will be sitting around in a
conference room,
put it forward that perspectives on this
issue and trying to find common ground
or trying not to find common ground,
just depending on what sort of outcome
that they're working towards.
So,
you know,
the UN isn't a completely separate
entity of its own.
It's just the community of states in the
world sitting together talking about
talking about things.
So main focus of concern and those
discussions when it comes to autonomy is
not some sort of generalized,
uh,
autonomy,
autonomy of all of its forms that may be
pertinent in the military space.
It's,
it's rather much more these,
these questions of how the targets of an
attack,
a selected,
uh,
identified,
decided upon.
And how is the decision to apply force
to those targets made.
And it's really a,
these sort of the critical functions of
weapons systems where the movement
towards greater autonomy is considered a
source of anxiety,
essentially that we may see machines
making decisions on what is a target for
an attack and choosing when and where
forces apply to that specific.
So that specific target.
So obviously in this context,
not everybody is like minded on this.
There are potential advantages to
increasing autonomy in weapons systems
and there's potential disadvantages and,
and,
uh,
problems associated with it.
Then within the,
within this,
uh,
international discussion,
we say different perspectives laid out
on some states.
Of course we'll be able to see some,
some advantages and some disadvantages.
It's not a black and white sort of a
discussion in terms of the possible
advantages for autonomy.
I mean one of the key ones ultimately is
framed in terms of military advantage
that we want to have more autonomy and
weapons systems because it will maintain
or give us military advantage over
possible adversaries.
Because in the end military stuff is
about winning wars,
right?
So you want to maintain military
advantage and military advantage number
of factors really within that speed is
one of them.
Speed of decision making can computerize
autonomous systems make decisions about
where to apply force faster than a human
would be capable of doing.
And therefore this is a,
this is advantageous for us.
Uh,
also,
speed allows for coordination of
numbers.
So if you want to have swarms of a
systems,
you know,
swarms of small drones or some such a
unique,
quite a lot of probably autonomy in
decision making and communication
between those systems because again,
the level of complexity and the speed
involved is,
is greater than a human would be able to
sort of manually a engineer.
So speed,
both in terms of responding to external
effects,
but also coordinating your own forces,
reach,
um,
potential for autonomous systems to be
able to operate in a communication
denied environments where if you're
relying on a,
on an electronic communications link to
say a current arm drone,
maybe in a future battle space where the
enemy is denying communications in some
way,
you could use an autonomous system to
still fulfill a mission without a,
without needing to rely on that
communications infrastructure,
general force multiplication.
There's a bit of a sense that there's
going to be more and more teaming of
machines with,
with humans,
so machines operating alongside humans
in the battle space.
And then this importantly as it presents
it at least a sense that these are
systems which could allow you to reduce
the risk to your own forces.
That maybe if we can put some sort of
autonomous robotic system at work in a
specific environment,
then we don't need to put one of our own
soldiers in that position.
And as a result,
we're less likely to have casualties
coming home.
Which of course politically is a
problematic for maintaining any sort of
conflict,
posture set against all that stuff.
Um,
there's a sense that I think most
fundamentally this perhaps a moral
hazard that we come across at some point
that the,
some sort of a boundary where seeing or
conceptualizing a situation where
machines are deciding who to kill in a
certain context is just somehow wrong
and well,
that's not a very easy argument to just
start,
you know,
articulate in a sort of rationalized
sense,
but there's some sort of moral revulsion
that perhaps it comes about at this
sense that machines are now deciding who
should be killed in a particular,
in a particular environment.
Um,
there's a set of legal concerns.
Can these systems be used in accordance
with the existing legal obligations?
And I'm going to come on a little bit
later to our orientation in the legal
side,
which is,
is also about how they may stretch the
fabric of the law and the structure of
the law.
As we say it.
The some concerns in this sort of legal
arguments for me that,
um,
we sometimes slip into a language of
talking about machines making legal
decisions.
Will a machine be able to apply the rule
of proportionality properly?
There's dangers in that.
I know what it means,
but at the same time the law is
addressed to humans.
The law isn't addressed to machines.
So it's humans who have the obligation
to,
uh,
an act,
the legal obligation and machine may do
a function that is sort of analogous to
that legal decision.
But ultimately to my mind is still a
human who has to be making the legal
determination based on some predict
prediction of what that machine will do.
And I think this is a very dangerous
slippage because even,
you know,
senior legal academics can slip into
this mindset which is,
which is a little bit like handing over
the legal framework to machines before
you've even got onto arguing about what
we should or shouldn't have.
So we need to be careful in that area.
And it's a little bit to do with,
for me continuing to treat these
technologies as machines rather than
into treating them as agents in some way
of sort of equal or equivalent or
similar moral standing to,
to humans.
And then we have a whole set of wider
concerns that are raised.
So we've got moral anxieties,
a legal concerns,
and then a set of other concerns around
risks,
uh,
that could be unpredictable risks,
does the sort of normal accidents
theory.
Maybe you've come across that stuff.
There's a bit of that sort of language
in the debate about complicated systems
and not been able to,
uh,
you know,
not be able to avoid accidents and in
some respects some anxieties about maybe
this will reduce the barriers to
engaging in military action,
may be being able to use autonomous
weapons,
will make it easier to go to war.
And some anxieties about sort of
international security and balance of
power and arms races and the like.
These are all significant concerns.
I don't tend to think much in this area,
partly because they involve quite a lot
of speculation about what may or may not
be in the future and they're quite
difficult to populate with,
um,
with sort of more grounded arguments I
find.
But uh,
that doesn't mean that they are
significant in themselves,
but I find them less straightforward as
an entry point.
So been all of these different issues.
There's multiple unstable terminology,
lots of arguments coming in,
different directions.
And our job as an NGO in a way is we're
trying to find ways of building a
constructive conversation in this
environment which can move toward states
adopting a more constraining orientation
to this movement towards autonomy.
And the main tool we've used to work
towards that so far has been to perhaps
stop focusing on the technology per se
and the idea of what is autonomy and how
much autonomy is a problem.
And to bring the focus back a bit onto
what is the human element that we want
to preserve in all of this.
Because it seems like most of the
anxieties that come from a sense of a
problem with autonomous weapons are
about some sort of absence of a human
element that we want to preserve,
but unless we can in some way define
what this human element is that we want
to preserve,
I'm not sure we can expect to define its
absence.
Very straightforward.
So I kind of feel like we want to pull
the discussion onto a focus on the,
on the human,
uh,
on the human element.
Um,
and the tool we've used for this so far
has been basically a terminology about
the need for meaningful human control.
And this is just a form of words that
we've sort of introduced into the debate
and we've promoted it in discussions
with diplomats and with different
actors.
And we've built up the idea of this
terminology as,
as being a sort of tool.
It's a bit like a meme,
right?
You,
you create the,
the terms and then you use that to sort
of structure the discussion in a,
in a productive,
in a productive way.
One of the reasons I like it is it works
partly because the word meaningful,
it doesn't mean anything particular or
at least it means whatever you might
want it to mean.
And I,
I find that,
uh,
an enjoyable sort of tension and in
that,
but the term meaningful human control
has been quite well picked up in and the
literature on this issue and in the
diplomatic discourse and it's helping to
structure us towards a,
uh,
what we think are the key questions,
basic arguments for the idea of
meaningful human control from my
perspective,
a quite simple and intended to use
basically a sort of absurdist sort of
logic if there is such a thing.
First of all,
really to recognize that no governments
are in favor of an autonomous weapon
system that has no human control
whatsoever,
right?
Nobody is arguing that it would be a
good idea for us to have some sort of
autonomous weapon that just flies around
the world deciding to kill people.
We don't know who it's gonna count a why
it doesn't have to report back to us,
but you know,
we're in favor.
Nobody's in favor of this,
right?
This is obviously ridiculous,
so there needs to be some form of human
control because we can rule out that
sort of ridiculous extension of the
argument and on the other hand,
if you just have a person in a dark room
with a red light that comes on every now
and again and they don't know anything
else about what's going on,
but that the human who's controlling
this autonomous weapon and when the red
light comes on,
they pushed the fire button to launch a
rocket or something.
We know that that isn't sufficient tumor
control either,
right?
There's a person doing something,
there's a person engaged in the process,
but clearly it's just some sort of
mechanistic,
pro forma human engagement.
So between these two kinds of ridiculous
extremes,
I think we get the idea that there's.
There's some sort of fuzzy,
fuzzy line that that must exist in
there,
in there somewhere and that everybody
can in some way agree to the idea that's
such a line should exist.
So the question then for us is how to
move the conversation in the
international community towards a
productive sort of discussion of where
the parameters of this line might be
conceptualized.
So that's brought us on to thinking
about a more substantive side of
questions about what are the key
elements of meaningful human control and
we've laid out some basic elements.
So I'm like,
get rid of that fuzzy line because it's
a bit useless anyway,
isn't it?
And then I can put my key elements on
here.
Well,
one of them is I'm predictable,
reliable,
transparent technology.
This is kind of before you get into
exactly what the system is going to do,
we want the technology itself to be sort
of well made and it's,
you know,
it's going to basically do what it says
it's going to do whatever that is and we
want to be able to understand it to some
extent.
Obviously this becomes a bit of a
challenge and some of the Ai type
functions where you start to have
machine learning,
uh,
issues and these issues of transparency.
Perhaps they start to come up a little
bit,
a little bit,
but these kinds of issues in the design
and the development of of of systems.
Another thing we want to have is,
and I think this is a key one,
is accurate information
and it's accurate information on the
intent of the commander.
Well the outcome,
what's the outcome we're trying to
achieve?
How does the technology work and what's
the context so it is already full so it
won't take long.
Third one is
timely intervention,
human intervention.
It should be.
It'd be good if we could turn it off
some points if it's going to be a very
long acting system would be good if we
turn it off.
Maybe that's the fourth one is just the
sort of framework of accountability.
So we're thinking the basic elements of
humor control can be broken down into
these areas.
Some of them have about the technology
itself,
how it's designed and made.
How do you verify and validate that it's
gonna do what the manufacturers have
said it's going to do.
Can you understand it?
This one I think is the key one in terms
of thinking about the issue and this is
what I'm going to talk about a bit more
now.
The accurate information on what's the
commander's intent,
what do you want to achieve in the use
of this system?
What effects is it going to have?
I mean this makes a big difference how
it works.
This factors here involve what are the
target profiles that it's going to use.
Whereas mine on the landmine,
of course it was just pressure.
Pressure is being taken as a pressure on
the ground is being taken as a proxy for
a military target for a human who we're
going to assume as a military target,
but,
and these systems,
we're going to have different target
profiles,
different heat shapes,
different,
uh,
different patterns of data that the
system is going to operate on.
The basis of what sort of actual weapons
are going to use to apply force.
It makes a difference if it's going to
just fire a bullet from a gun or if it's
gonna drop a 2000 pound bomb.
I mean,
that has a different effect.
And the way in which you envision sort
of control for those effects is going to
be different in those different cases.
And finally,
very importantly,
these issues of context,
information on the context in which the
system will will operate.
Okay.
Contexts of course,
includes all the going to be civilians
present in the area.
Can you assess,
are they going to be other objects in
the area that may present a similar
pattern to the proxy data?
You know,
if you're using a heat shape of a
vehicle engine,
oh,
it might be aimed at a tank,
but if there's an ambulance in the same
location is an ambulance,
is vehicle engine heat shape
sufficiently similar to the tank to
cause some confusion between the two
sets of information like that?
And context of course varies in
different.
You know,
obviously varies in different
environments.
But I think we can see different domains
in this area as well,
which is significant operating in the
water or in the ocean.
You've probably got a less cluttered
environment or less complex environment
than if you're operating in an urban in
an urban area.
So that's another factor that needs to
be taken into,
into accountant in this.
So I just wanted to talk a little bit
about some existing perhaps and think
about them in the context of this,
these sort of set of issues here.
One system that you may maybe aware of
is it's on a boat.
Um,
okay.
So,
so then like the Phalanx,
anti missile system,
it's on a boats,
but there's various anti missile
systems.
I mean it doesn't,
the details don't matter in this
context.
These are systems that human terms that
aren't so human is choosing when to turn
it on and a human turns it off again.
But when it's operating it's the radar
is basically scanning and area of an
area of sky up here.
And it's looking for fast moving
incoming objects because basically it's
designed to automatically shoot down
incoming missiles.
Rockets,
right?
So thinking about these characteristics,
you know,
what the outcome you want is you want
your boat not to get blown up by an
incoming missile and you want to shoot
down any incoming missiles.
You know,
how the technology works because you
know that it's basically using radar to
see incoming fast moving,
uh,
signatures and you have a pretty good
idea of the context because the sky is a
fairly uncluttered comparatively and
you'd like to think that any fast moving
incoming objects towards your hair are
probably going to be a incoming
missiles,
not guaranteed to be the case.
One of these systems shut down,
uh,
an Iranian passenger airliner,
but,
uh,
by accident,
which is obviously a significant
accident,
um,
but basically you have a sentence of,
you know,
the fact that the data that you're using
tracks pretty well to the target
objects,
if not absolutely precisely.
You Bet are relatively controllable
environments in terms of the sky and
you've got a human being.
The system isn't really mobile.
I mean,
it's kind of mobile insofar as the boat
can move around,
but the person who's operating it as you
know,
the mobile in the same place.
So,
uh,
so it's relatively static.
So I think looking at that,
you could suggest that there's still a
reasonable amount of human control over
this system because when we look at it
in terms of a number of the functions
here,
we can understand how that,
um,
how that system is being managed in a
human controls by and although there's
still a degree of autonomy or at least
it's sort of highly automated and the
way that it actually identifies the
targets and moves the gun and shoots
down the incoming object.
The basic framework is volume,
which I fail like it.
I mean,
it's not for me to say,
but I feel like I'm still a reasonable
amount of human controlled is bang,
Bang,
applaud.
Okay.
Another sort of system.
I'm gonna draw some tanks or something
now say,
okay,
well I'm just going to draw them out a
lot because otherwise it's too long.
Days of tanks all but fighting vehicles.
Ignore the graphic design skills.
Um,
there a sense of use weapons systems,
Blah commander,
a significant distance,
right?
Can't necessarily see the location of
the,
of the tanks,
but they know that the cement tanks in
this area over here,
right,
and maybe they have some sense of what
this area is that aren't in the middle
of a town.
They're out in the open so they have an
understanding of the context,
but maybe not a detailed understanding
of the context.
So the weapons system is going to file
multiple warheads into this target area.
The commander is decided upon the target
of the attack,
this group of tanks here,
but as the war heads approached the
target area,
the warheads are going to communicate
amongst themselves and that kind of
allocate it themselves to the specific
to the specific objects.
And I got to detect the heat shape of
the vehicles engines.
They're going to match that with some
profile that says this is a enemy almost
fighting vehicle as far as we're
concerned.
And then they're going to apply force
downwards from the,
uh,
using a better of explosive engineering
shape charge which focus a plus a plus
to have explosive basically a jet of
explosives downwards onto the specific
targets.
And so in this situation,
well have the,
has the weapon system chosen the target?
It's a bit ambiguous because as long as
we conceptualize the group of tanks as
the as the target,
then a human has chosen the target and
the weapon system is essentially just
being efficient in its distribution of
force to the target objects.
But if we see the individual vehicles as
individual targets,
maybe the weapon system has chosen a,
the targets potentially some advantages
of automated of autonomy in this
situation.
From my perspective,
this kind of ability to focus a jet of
explosive force directly on the object
that you're looking to strike so long as
you've got the right object.
This is much better than setting off
lots of artillery shells in this area,
which would have a much greater
explosive force effect on the
surrounding area.
Probably put a wider population at risk.
So just sort of set of considerations
here that I think a significant.
So we have these systems,
these systems exist,
exist today.
You could ask questions about whether
those heat shaped profiles of those
objects sufficiently tightly tied to
energy fighting vehicles or whatever.
But I think it can be conceptualized
reasonably straightforwardly in those
times,
but the area where I started having a
problem with this stuff is in the
potential for this circle or this
pattern just to get bigger and bigger
essentially because it's all reasonably
straightforward.
When you put the tanks reasonably close
together and you can envisage having one
sort of one set of information about
this area which allows you to make a
legal determination is that you need to
make.
But once these tanks get spread out over
a much larger area and you have a weapon
system that using basically the same
sorts of technological approach is able
to cover a substantially wider area of
enemy terrain over a longer period of
time.
Then it suddenly gets much more
difficult for the.
For the military commander to have any
really detailed information about the
context in which force will actually be
applied.
And for me,
this is.
I think the main point of anxiety or
point of concern that I have in the way
in which autonomy and weapons systems
is,
is likely to develop over the immediate
future.
Because under the legal framework,
a military commander has an obligation
to apply certain rules in an attack and
an attack is.
It's not precisely defined,
but it needs to have some,
I think,
some spatial and conceptual boundaries
to it that allow a sufficient
granularity of legal application.
Because if you.
If you treat this as an attack,
I think that's fine as you expand it
out,
so you've got vehicles across a whole
wide area of a country,
say across the country as a whole,
using the same sort of extension logic
has as in some previous arguments.
Once you've got vehicles across the
whole country and you're saying,
in this attack,
I'm going to just talk at the vehicles
of the enemy and you send out your
warheads across the whole location.
Now,
I don't think that's gonna happen in the
immediate term,
but I'm just using that as a sort of
conceptual challenge.
You start to have applications of actual
physical force in all sorts of locations
where a commander really can't assess in
any realistic way what the actual
effects of that are going to be.
And I think at that point you can't.
You can no longer say that there is
sufficient a human control being being
applied,
so this capacity of ai enabled systems
or ai driven systems to expand the
attacks across a much wider geographical
area and potentially over a longer
period of time I think is a significant
challenge to how the legal framework is,
is understood at present,
not one that relies upon determinations
about whether this weapon system will
apply the rules properly or not,
but rather one which involves the
frequency and the proximity of human
decision making to be sort of diluted a
progressively over progressively over
time.
So that's a significant area of concern
for me.
Final sort of set of concerns in these
areas is around these issues about
encoding of targets.
I think we could say pretty clearly that
weight is a very mega,
a basis for evaluating whether something
is a valid military target.
All right,
um,
the significant problems,
but it's suggesting that we could just
take the weight of something as being
sufficient for us to decide is this a
target or not.
In any of these processes,
we have to decide that certain patterns
of data represent a military objects of
some type and of course in a way I think
what we sort of see in sort of
proponents of greater and greater
autonomy and weapons systems is a sense
that,
well,
as we expand the scope of this attack,
we just need to have a more
sophisticated system that's undertaking
the attack that can take on more of the
evaluation and,
and more of this,
um,
process of basically mapping the coding
of the world into a set of decisions
about the application of force.
But overall,
yeah,
I'm skeptical about the way in which our
social systems are likely to go about
mapping people's indicators of
identities into some sort of fixed sense
of military objects or military targets
as a society over the last hundred
years.
There's been plenty of times where we've
applied certain labels to certain types
of people,
certain groups of people,
um,
based on various indicators,
which apparently seemed reasonable to
some significant section of society at
the time.
But then ultimately I think we've
subsequently thought,
well,
highly problematic.
And so I think we need to be very wary
of any sort of ideas of thinking that we
can encode in terms of humans,
particularly I'm very concrete
indicators that certain groups of people
should be considered by the targets or
not just going to say a couple of final
things about future discussions in the
CCW.
The chair of the Group of governmental
experts,
that's the body that's going discuss
autonomous weapons,
uh,
has us states for the next meeting we
should take place in April to come
prepared with ideas about the
touchpoints of human machine
interaction.
This is a sort of code for one of the
ways in which we can control technology.
So I suppose from our context as an
organization,
we'll be looking to get states to start
to try and lay out this kind of
framework as being the basis for their
perception of the ways in which the
entry points to control of technology
could be thought about.
Again,
it's really a question of structuring
the debate.
We won't get into detail across all of
this,
but I think it's plausible that this
year and next we'll start to see the
debate falling into some adoption of
this kind of framework,
which I think will give us some tools to
work with.
I think at least if we start to get some
agreement from a significant body of
states that these are the sort of entry
points we should be thinking about in
terms of control of technology that will
give us a bit of leverage for a start
towards suggesting an overarching
obligation that there should be some
sort of meaningful or sufficient human
control,
um,
but also in a way of thinking about that
and interrogating that as new
technologies develop in the future,
uh,
that we can leverage in some.
In some ways I felt reasonably confident
about that.
But it's a difficult political
environment and you know,
it's quite possible that I don't see any
rush amongst states to move towards any
legal controls in this,
in this area.
Just as a few very final thoughts,
which may be a bit more abstract in my
thinking on this.
I feel like,
and this sort of reflecting on maybe
some dynamics of ai functioning,
my anxiety here about the expansion of
the concept of attacks and in the same,
in conjunction with that,
a sort of breaking down of the
granularity of the legal framework.
I think this is another,
a sort of generalizing function again,
and it's a movement away from more
specific legal application by humans to
perhaps a pushing humans people towards
a more general,
a legal orientation.
And I feel like in the context of
conflict,
we should be pushing for a more specific
and more focused and more regular,
um,
application of human judgments and
moral.
A moral agency that isn't to say that I
think humans are perfect in any way.
Uh,
there's lots of problems with humans,
but at the same time I think the,
we should be very wary of thinking that
violence is something that can be
somehow perfected and that we can encode
how to conduct violence in some
machinery that will then provide an
adequate social product for society as
a,
as a whole.
And I guess it was a very final thought,
a bit linked to that is some questions
in my mind about how this all relates to
bureaucracy in a way and in a sense that
some of the functions that we're saying
here and some of the Ai functions that
we see here in many ways related to
bureaucracy,
to the encoding and categorization of
data in certain ways and just a very
fast management of that bureaucracy,
which is really an extension of the
bureaucracies that we already,
that we already have.
And I think extending that to far into
the world of violence and the
application of force to people will well
precipitate painful effects for us as a,
as a society.
And as it brings to the fore.
I think some of the underpinning
underpinnings of the rationales of that,
uh,
of that bureaucratic framework so that
we go.
It's a bit of a broad brush sketch.
Thank you.
So,
um,
this question's kind of a little bit of
multifaceted,
but,
um,
as humans evolve and adapt to
increasingly autonomous weapons,
the complexity and sophistication could
increase with expansion of targets and
types and target area is.
Do you think there's a limit to which we
can prepare against such an evolution
and a,
do you think that'd be ocracy can keep
up with how fast these,
the autonomy of you couldn't develop
over time?
Yeah,
I'm not sure I caught all the first bit
of the question,
but there's definitely,
it's definitely a challenge that the
types of legal discussions at the UN
Convention on Conventional Weapons,
they are not famous for going too
quickly.
In fact,
they're incredibly slow.
And in that framework,
every state essentially has a veto over
everything.
So even over the agenda of the next
meeting,
if you know,
if the US wants to block the agenda,
they can lock the agenda,
let alone block the outcome that might
come if you could agree on agenda.
So,
so every state has an ability to keep
things moving very slowly there.
And that's definitely a challenge in the
context where the pace of technological
development moves pretty quickly.
The only thing I would say,
which I forgot to mention before in
terms of thinking about the dynamics in
this debate,
is that it's not straightforwardly a
situation where militaries really want
loads more autonomous weapons and other
people don't have in military commanders
also like control and they they like
troops on the ground like control and
they like trust and confidence in the
systems that they're operating around.
They don't want to get blown up by their
own equipment and military commanders
like controlling and like to know what's
happening.
So there are some constraints within the
military structures as well.
So the overall sort of development here,
I guess from our side in terms of this
sort of how to constrain against the
expansion of attacks and the expansion
of sort of objects that may be attacked
by autonomous systems in a way.
That's where I felt like developing the
idea that there's a principle of human
control that needs to be applied.
Even if it's a bit fuzzy in its
boundaries,
we can use that and interrogated as a
social process to try and keep
constraint going back towards the
specific because in the end,
like I said earlier,
these legal structures or sort of social
processes as well and it's not very
easy.
It's not something where you can just
straightforward to draw a line and then
no new technologies will come along that
challenge your expectations,
right?
We need to find the sort of camp on the
international legal political landscape.
We need to sketch out the parameters of
that come in legal terms.
Then we need people to turn up at those
meetings and continuously complain about
things and put pressure on things
because that's the only way over time
where you maintain that sort of
interrogation of future technologies as
they come out of the pipeline or or
whatever.
So it's a sort of social I think.
Yeah,
that answered my question is like the
balance between like how fast science
would be like advancing in this field
versus like how fast we obviously can
move to keep up
be resolved.
I think it's an ongoing.
It's got to be an ongoing social
political process in a way.
Right.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So
given that this course is on Agi and
we'll likely see a wide variety of
different kinds of autonomous systems in
the future,
can you give us perhaps some sort of
extrapolation from this domain to a
broader set of potentially risky
behaviors that more autonomous and more
intelligent systems would do and ways
that the creators of such systems such
as potentially the folks sitting in this
room can change what they're doing to
make those safer?
Yeah,
I mean I think useful to think about in
some ways these ideas of from the
president,
from where we are now,
how can people involved in developing
different technologies,
new technological capacities,
just be thinking of the potential
outcomes in this sort of weaponization
area and building in some orientation to
their work that thinks about that and
thinks about what the potential
consequences of work can be.
I mean,
I think in some ways the risk outcomes
type thinking.
I mean again,
it gets you into hypothetical arguments,
but they.
The idea of two sides,
both with substantial autonomous weapons
system capabilities is probably the sort
of area where these ideas of accidental
escalations come to the fore,
that if you've got to adversarily
orientated states with substantial
autonomous systems,
then there's a potential for
interactions to occur between those
systems that rapidly escalating violence
situation in a way that greater capacity
for human engagement would allow you to,
to curtail it and stole it.
And I think,
I mean I know in other areas of,
you know,
of Algo written functioning in society,
we've seen aspects of that,
right?
And sort of probably in the financial
sector and other such location.
So.
So I think yeah,
those are those ideas of sort of rapidly
escalating,
cascading risks is a,
is a,
is a concern in that area.
But again,
based on hypothetical thinking about
stuff.
Last question,
right?
What do you think of this criteria?
So we have this tank example on the
right,
our simulations,
our ability to simulate things is
getting better and better.
What if we showed a simulation of what
would happen to a person that has the
ability to hit the go button on it and
if the simulation does not have enough
fidelity,
we consider that a Nogo we cannot do
that.
Or if the simulation shows it does have
enough fidelity and it shows a,
a bad outcome,
then maybe that would be a criteria in
which to,
uh,
to judge this circumstance on the right.
And that could also let us a,
as that circle gets bigger and bigger,
it can let us kind of put a,
uh,
it could let us cap that by saying,
hey,
if we don't,
if we do not have enough information to
make this a simulation to even show the
person,
then it's a no go.
Yup.
I think in a way this is an issue of
modeling,
right?
Based on contextual information that
you,
that you have.
So maybe with technological developments
you have a better capacity for modeling
specific situations.
I suppose the challenge is how do you,
in a sort of timely manner,
especially in a conflict environment
where tempo is significant.
Can you,
can you put the data that you have into
some sort of modeling system adequately,
but I don't see any problem with the
idea of using ai to model the outcomes
of specific attacks and you know,
give you read outs on what the likely
effects are going to be.
I guess the challenges that,
what counts are adequate effect where
the boundary lines have sufficient
information and insufficient information
fall that kind of open questions as
well.
Right.
And you know,
military is tend to like to leave some
openness on those,
those points as well.
But,
but I think that can be definitely a
goal for modeling and in better
understanding what the facts.
It cannot be great.
Give Richard a big hand.
Thank you very much.